[Music]
on this Saturday night repatriating
Canadians in Syria a judge orders Ottawa
to help release four men with alleged
ties to Isis I strongly believe we're
all going to get off scott-free
residential school settlement this is
the beginning of a new era in Canada for
our people the 2.8 billion dollar
agreement in a class-action suit for
loss of language and culture
the 50th anniversary of Roe v Wade we
will March until abortion is Unthinkable
why some anti-abortion activists are
celebrating
and Mayan Mysteries researchers reveal
what they believe is the world's first
ever highway system
global national
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
bring them home that's the message from
a federal court judge who has ruled four
Canadian men detained in Syria must be
returned to their home country despite
their alleged ties to Isis the decision
says not doing so violates their
constitutional rights but it's a rarity
for the federal government to repatriate
its citizens from Syria as Mackenzie
gray reports in our top story tonight
the men's future once they get to Canada
remains unclear
after years stuck in a Syrian prison
camp four Canadian men with allegedized
Isis could be brought home by the
Canadian government in a federal court
ruling Justice Henry Brown says the four
men aren't able to return to Canada in
part because the government seems to
never have formally requested their
repatriation because of that brown ruled
the men aren't able to meaningfully
exercise their Charter rights leading
the court to State Canada must make a
formal request for the repatriation it's
clear that there's no will or intention
to try these men they haven't even been
charged with anything the highest
profile detainee Jack lets dubbed Jihadi
Jack by the British media lets was a
dual UK Canadian citizen but his British
passport was revoked in 2019 after he
allegedly joined Isis his family
maintains that leads didn't go to Syria
to join the terrorist group and that he
was tortured while there Jack himself
opposed dayesh he was arrested and
imprisoned three separate times by them
and he was escaping from Ash let's and
the other men haven't been heard from
since 2021 but despite that they could
face charges if they returned to Canada
last Fall Canada repatriated two women
from the Syrian camps and immediately
charged them with terrorist related
offenses but getting a conviction on
those charges can be difficult I
strongly believe they're all going to
get off scot-free uh not pay any price
in terms of Justice never see any
significant time in jail and more
arrests could be coming after the
Canadian government agreed on Friday to
bring home an additional Six Women and
13 children from the Syrian camps this
would be the largest repatriation of
Canadian citizens with alleged ties to
Isis conditions in those camps are dire
Human Rights Watch says that most live
in tents without adequate food and water
the syrians have asked foreign countries
to take back the estimated 38 000
foreign Nationals who are being held
what did these innocent children done to
deserve to start the you know start
their lives or have their early stages
of their lives in detention camps Global
Affairs says it's currently reviewing
the decision and will have more to say
in due course the Safety and Security of
Canadians is our government's top
priority and the Canadian government
does have options they could appeal the
case up to the federal court of appeal
which could potentially halt the four
men coming back to Canada as for the
women and children the lawyer
representing the family say the federal
government has come to an agreement with
them nithu on a timeline for them
returning to Canada
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa for us tonight
thanks Mackenzie
the federal government has reached a 2.8
billion dollar agreement to settle a
residential school class action lawsuit
brought forward by two First Nations in
BC related to the harms caused by the
institutions of assimilation
and while settlements that are being
announced like these today
do not erase
or make up for the past what it can do
is help address the collective harm
caused by Canada's past a deeply
Colonial one
if approved by the court the feds will
pay into a new trust fund that will
operate for 20 years independent of the
government this is the first time bands
specifically are being compensated with
funds set to support the Revival and
protection of indigenous languages and
cultures
the second off-duty police officer
caught in an avalanche in BC nearly two
weeks ago has now died Constable Matthew
nolay with the Nelson Police Department
was Backcountry skiing alongside
Constable Wade titamore near caslow when
they were Swept Away titamore died on
scene his funeral was held this week no
lay was located by Witnesses and rushed
to hospital he suffered severe internal
injuries and died this morning
Alberta Premier Danielle Smith is
promising to look into allegations her
staffer emailed crowd prosecutors to
influence cases linked to last year's
anti-government Border blockades in
Coots on a radio show today Smith says
she's launching a review conducted by
independent public servants and I.T
workers for the alleged political
interference she also says emails
between 400 Crown prosecutors and 34
staffers will need to be reviewed and
results are expected early next week she
also confirmed an emergency Caucus
meeting was held today over the matter
more than a year since Afghanistan fell
to the Taliban takeover Canada has
accepted more than half of the 40 000
refugees it pledged to take in from that
country despite that many vulnerable
Afghans are still stuck there fearing
for their lives while waiting for the
help Canada promised them and for some
it's already too late for the West block
this week Mercedes Stevenson looks at
the growing pressure on the federal
government to do more Mercedes
neither the murder of a woman Member of
Parliament in Afghanistan who was shot
and killed in Kabul has reignited the
discussion about Canada trying to help
vulnerable Afghans especially women and
girls as the Taliban systematically
eliminates women's rights and freedoms
in Afghanistan this week on the west
block we are looking at whether the
government of Canada is living up to its
promises and saving those who are in the
most danger and still inside Afghanistan
often on the run and in hiding Heather
McPherson the ndp's Foreign Affairs
critic is one of a group of Canadian
politicians of all political Stripes who
are trying to save Afghan women members
of parliament that included the woman
who was executed McPherson is calling on
the liberal government to do more and
faster I don't know what the holdup is
to be perfectly honest that the
government the minister Minister Fraser
has the capacity to do this he for
shagufa Donna she was a political
journalist and anchor with Tolo news a
major Afghan television network this
story resonates on a deeper level
shagufa spent much of this week talking
to women MPS who are in hiding in
Afghanistan fear they could be killed as
the Taliban searches for them she says
that women who are trapped there don't
understand why countries like Canada
aren't doing more they are countries
that they always talk about the freedom
democracy woman rights they were feminet
they were supporting these things but
now why they cannot do anything for them
a group of Canadian veterans trying to
help Afghans who worked for the Canadian
Forces say little is being done to
rescue those who are at the most risk
and still inside Afghanistan what I'd
really like to see is the Canadian
government fly Afghans directly from
Afghanistan to Canada another major
crisis the war in Ukraine and its
implications for energy security is
feeding the debate around Canadian Oil
and Gas the federal government wants to
move away from it meanwhile the Alberta
Premier says that risks economic
disaster we'll also be talking about the
controversy over the just transition the
Fed Federal government's talking about
and whether or not oil companies have a
responsible plan to move forward as they
plan to up production methu Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thanks Mercedes to
Peru now where dozens of people are dead
as a result of its worst political
violence in decades
demonstrators clashed with police again
in Lima last night demanding the
president's resignation while the
government responded with a deadly
Crackdown access to Machu Picchu was
also suspended stranding hundreds of
tourists still in the area all this
happening over last month's ousting and
arrest of Peru's former president tariya
isri explains how it got to this point
is here anger is exploding on the
streets of Peru a nation sliding towards
Anarchy
rows of police and riot gear are
squaring off with protesters in running
battles across the country highways are
blocked airports shut down and the
capital Lima is paralyzed
it's Nationwide chaos says this map you
can't live like this the uncertainty the
vandalism a massive fire ripped through
a historic building during clashes
between security forces and
anti-government demonstrators
that was not a peaceful protest says
Peruvian president Dina biluarte these
violent acts will not go unpunished Peru
is living through one of the most
dramatic moments in recent decades that
its entire political system is under
assault the chaos began last month when
Peru's then-president Pedro Castillo
tried to dissolve Congress before an
impeachment vote he was ousted then
arrested vice president baluorte was
sworn in as the new leader triggering
demonstrations from Castillo supporters
who see him as the rightful leader many
have traveled to the Capitol from remote
parts of the Andes the rural region
Castillo is from
we are defending our country says this
protester from a dictatorial government
that has Stained our country with blood
Security Forces Unleashed a deadly
Crackdown after Peru granted police
sweeping powers
the country has seen six presidents in
less than six years Latin American
experts say the political instability
has been compounded by a financial
crisis the whole region has experienced
a devastating consequences of the covet
pandemic uh that's been followed by a
real economic hardship
um including you know Rising prices
um slowing of economic growth many
people in the middle class is feeling
that they're sinking back max Cameron
believes this crisis points to an
erosion of trust in governments across
South America Peruvian protesters want
the president to step down elections
called and for the Constitution to be
Rewritten in a crisis already rewriting
the history of Peru teria Israeli Global
News
Ottawa
New Politics of abortion coming up March
for Life demonstrators shift their focus
on the 50th anniversary of Roe v Wade
in the U.S this weekend marks 50 years
since the Supreme Court ruled in favor
of Roe versus Wade giving women the
constitutional right to abortion the
same right that was struck down by the
now conservative leaning Court's
majority last year now the anniversary
is being marked by pro-life protests
across the country while being met by
pro-choice counter protests as the
battle over the right to abortion in
America continues Jennifer Johnson
reports
for the first time since the U.S Supreme
Court overturned Roe v Wade March for
Life demonstrators are celebrating we
will March until abortion is
the Supreme Court's decision left
abortion access laws up to each state
now the focus of anti-abortion activists
is on federal restrictions or a total
ban from the new republican-controlled
house the next phase now begins and
that's what this year's March is all
about the next steps in a post-row era
since the end of row the nation has
become even more divided over abortion
rights there is now a patchwork of bans
or partial bans in several States
but abortion rights activists are vowing
not to give up their fight either I'm
support women's rights and the women's
right to choose States like Florida
still allow abortions up to 15 weeks but
there's a total ban on abortions in
three nearby States a Planned Parenthood
clinic in North Florida is now swamped
with women from other states seeking
abortions ramping up anti-abortion
activists here in Florida we're pushing
for a complete abortion ban doctors say
the battle is putting pregnant women at
risk women are going trying to die
because
of what has happened to Reproductive
Rights in this country some studies show
a more than 60 percent increase in
maternal deaths in states with abortion
restrictions the situation is so dire
some doctors report women are now asking
for complete sterilizations and they're
so scared they don't even want to gamble
with anything that they want just
permanent contraceptives they're coming
to universalization doctors are now
caught in the crosshairs of a nationwide
battle with the Battlegrounds now
shifting to Congress and State
legislatures across the country
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
[Music]
we're now far enough into January that
some of us may have been having a bit of
trouble keeping those resolutions we
made a few weeks ago it's not easy to
keep those promises to ourselves
especially when we're talking about
major vices like alcohol and drugs Mike
trolllay explains how some Canadians are
dealing with their withdrawal symptoms
walking through an urban center can be a
test on one's senses the lights sounds
and smells can pull us in or drag us
down for Cal Stewart It's the smell of
weed which he loves yet for someone
trying to cut back it's an ubiquitous
enticement quite similar to the way that
one may salivate when they smell really
good food Stuart has smoked weed almost
daily for the last 15 years he found it
increased his focus and heightened his
sensory experiences but he realized
during the pandemic it was all just too
much so we vowed to cut back that proved
difficult while on vacation in
Montenegro in 2021 he went cold turkey
and was miserable and the first five
days were just awful light sensitivity
irritability lack of appetite all
stemming from marijuana withdrawal when
he returned to Canada where marijuana is
legal he just picked up where he left
off he needed a new approach so we tried
the fitness tracker method but instead
of counting his steps he was counting
the hours between the times he was
smoking
and so far it's working while Cal is at
the beginning of his refresh so that's
the honey syrup Sarah Kate is three
years into hers a glass of wine or three
had become her crutch in social
situations but unlike cow she quit her
Vice completely I feel great I have
changed my whole life has changed I've
stopped fighting with my husband I'm
more present for my kids I'm a lot more
even keeled I'm not grumpy she hasn't
looked back nor has she given up her
social life some club soda and is now
something of an expert on non-alcoholic
cocktails three years ago I could never
have dreamed I could make a
non-alcoholic Margarita that tastes
exactly like the real thing I I dreamed
about it and here we are today I will
make you a margarita and you will be
floored
cutting back or cutting out looks
different for everybody Cal Stewart
knows he'll have rough days ahead but if
he can get control of his vice he knows
he'll be happier for it micro light
Global News Toronto
Cal's story is so relatable to anyone
who's trying to push through Temptations
and keep up with their New Year's
resolutions whatever those may be and
joining us now with tips on how to
successfully see them through is
clinical psychologist Dr Dominique
morasano thank you so much for joining
us
yeah happy to be here so you work with
patients with substance use disorders
extremely tough addictions to overcome
what are the most common barriers you
see your patients face in their recovery
I would say probably the number one
barrier is the person themselves and
kind of
not you know having the confidence to
overcome their goals or to get like
giving up to soon
and you know I would say also the
environment that they live in or you
know work in you know and people around
them you know for instance if they're
living with other people who use
substances uh having everybody kind of
in alignment around you know that
person's goals and and knowing that
people will support them and not kind of
try to
um
you know tempt them you've met
research has focused on goal setting to
help your patients can you tell us why
this is being so effective for them
well you know personal goal setting is
effective for people in general it's
amazing what a difference it can make
when someone sets a goal you know says
it out loud writes it down and thinks
about the steps that they need to take
to achieve that goal it really has an
impact on overall outcomes and goal
success we know that from goal Theory
and goal setting research that having
just having a goal that is an important
goal to someone actually impacts mood
and so it makes people feel good to have
important goals that they're working
towards
what is your advice to anyone
persevering right now and trying to make
permanent changes in their life so I
would say to start small because little
goals pave the road for big goals so for
instance if you're thinking about you
know reducing the amount of cannabis
that you that you use maybe saying okay
I have
um I'm smoking you know or using seven
grams a week maybe think about aiming
for five grams that week or you know
moving back the time that you start
smoking in the day so once you achieve
something small it makes you feel good
it gives you confidence in yourself and
then you can actually say you know what
I was able to do that maybe I can try
this big or harder thing Dr morrisano
thank you so much for your advice on
this topic
absolutely it's been a pleasure
[Music]
next the suspected Stone highway system
hidden in the jungle
[Music]
technology is revealing new details
about an old civilization the ancient
Maya are known for a number of historic
advances they developed two thousand
years ago now a research team based in
Guatemala is drilling down on new
findings from even earlier times Ross
Lord reports
seeing through these thick jungles is
impossible unless you have technology on
your side fortunately researchers have
Ancient Maya settlements in northern
Guatemala and southern Mexico do have
high-tech assistance lidar which stands
for light detection and ranging taking a
penetrating look at the not so obvious
exposing all of the built features and
their interconnections with hydraulic
systems with Transportation networks
causeways and residential zones lid
hours becoming very popular some newer
iPhones and iPads have it it's also used
for self-driving cars for drones and for
augmented reality headsets for the Maya
Discovery lidar used planes to shoot
pulses of light into dense forest so
researchers could peel away vegetation
and make a map of ancient structures
based on the results the research team
has compiled 3D images of hundreds of
Maya locations that were previously
unknown including what they believe was
the world's first Highway Network Made
of Stone some of the highways were 40
meters wide and elevated five meters off
the ground they were created roughly 3
000 years ago centuries before the Mayan
Empire's breakthroughs in math and
writing
archaeologist Josue Garcia says it shows
how groups of people were connected
within the same site and with others in
their region so now that we know the
exact GPS locations we can plan for our
field seasons and go excavate in
particular areas and ask the type of
questions that scientists really want to
know examining just how complex life was
here 30 centuries ago new installments
in the continuous search for knowledge
Ross Lord Global News
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm nitu garcha tonight's
your Canada is this porcupine in Elk
Island National Park Alberta